[Music]
in helpful husband news like helpful
submitted by your secret admirer who
would be a secret if I told you that
asked roll a human has filed for divorce
after two weeks of marriage because her
husband does all the housework oh [ __ ]
don't be still a roll man wouldn't you
love it she don't want no business
that's why okay never mind I'm scared of
them so she divorced him because he was
too clean he did all the house and she's
like you're asking all of it and I said
no but some of it yes that's fine isn't
that a dream come true though it is for
me yeah like you wake up and all the
[ __ ] the clothes are [ __ ] folded
and [ __ ] that's like the only thing she
has to do at home and then authority
done it's like what I do myself she
could start painting or something
through yeah it opens up a lot of free
time giving you more time to do what you
love
uh-huh some people don't what they love
to do he's servitude and taking care of
people like that's their joy she's one
of those girls that are like can you
just beat me like an old-fashioned
husband instead of [ __ ] cleaning the
house or like a S&M girl yeah I get
scared Bonnie she has all values people
who live to like serve others like that
sometimes I especially like your family
what happens when they get older and
then they're out of the house you feel
like you lose your purpose sometimes
that's why moms are so Laurie that's my
mom long right now she's killing it
she's doing a great job being a better
center of one of my first is his wife
well I guess so they're friends but a
lot older but they're kids going off to
college issues like oh my god I hope
he's okay I was like he goes to a vide
the safest city on earth what are you
talking about look I can't wait till
Tiger goes to cars you get my free time
- [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out the house good yeah I was
talking our because we're talking about
should we have a second kid and I was
like well this back-to-back right now
oh I don't know just just in the macro
sense in the macro sense I was like you
know what just think about like right
now of course it's gonna be tough we
don't we barely get enough sleep as it
is if we have a second one I've even
less
time but we were 40 or 50 and when we're
having Thanksgiving dinners do we want
to have two guys sitting across the
table or one guy sitting across the
table so you're not gonna have a girl
keep other people to people I'd rather
have two people in our small little
family and that is CUNY er you know what
we did because we have such a small
family here in Thanksgiving we just
combined them
we combined because they only had like a
kid or two and we only had so with these
combined everything so it'd be end up
being like 20 people that's our family
by itself
I want a legion of children to make my
hair grey and [ __ ] upset within the
next two years paperclip thumbtack and
[ __ ] Vaseline I want to pawn off my
children to you guys what I have too
many [ __ ] kids dude you guys got to
hold them for me can you just feed them
Vaseline
go to Uncle Dave take care of one of
your kids yeah you could get practice
yes it was woman she's a 28 year old
Egyptian woman Egyptian she's known as
Samar and what a beautiful name if I had
it was tomorrow no way tomorrow was bad
from the ring oh yeah okay so her
husband who's 31 he goes his name is
Mohammed he runs a very successful
clothing store and so he has employees
and several staff members are Marty's
are us he's able to afford to spend a
lot of time home cuz he has other people
running his business and so Samar is
claiming that now he just spends all his
time at home cleaning and rearranging
the furniture and that she just can no
longer handle living with him anymore
there's nothing man anymore also he's a
Tweaker
rearranging the furniture every other
she says this quote we've been married
for just two weeks I've known and loved
him for over two years but I hate living
with him and can no longer handle his
actions my husband is a housewife he
doesn't let me touch anything in her
house and does all the cooking cleaning
in general household chores he controls
everything in her house and I have no
say in any even such as old dick so he
can lick his own balls yeah she
continues not even where he puts the TV
set even though he owns his own business
he hired people to manage it in order
for him to stay at home which while I
sit and watch that's all like she can't
do anything that's Plan C that's not
cool because she feels like she's a
guest in her own home yeah and that I do
not like because a person that I was
with still AM with he used to do that to
me on paper though he sounds like a
dream come true he has a successful
business he takes care of everything and
on top of that he's really into doing
housework you would hate that [ __ ]
though most guys are not into doing
housework it sounds like he's just at
home all day just rearranging like I'm
like easy Maggie easy Maggie is what he
is I already know hey why'd you move
that there yeah yeah don't do that why
are you writing that you're gonna put
stains over there
stop I'll move this over here it is
better no I'm switching this way ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] where's my shotgun it's
like you can't breathe yeah then what's
your place even if you're not a female
you know like as just a spouse what's
your role in that like he's making the
money and taking care of the house like
what do you either the pit know what I'm
saying if I was a girl in that situation
right and daddy wanted to take care of
everything
I feel getting some mad hobbies though
mmm like stuck in somebody else's doing
I kind of got like a routine going on
with Jess we're like I know I can't
clean like if I had to clean a room
it'll take me four days and it will take
her probably 30 minutes yeah so because
I know that like when we go into clean
mode my mind goes blank and I'm her
extra hands move this do that do this
here I just like I'm on autopilot and
then like it gives me time to start
singing in my head or do something more
important while this is being dry
whatever and then everything's done real
fast because we team work it but then
all the other stuff though I don't get
really Magda everything is just done oh
we can ignore the fact that all he said
is that you gonna he just sings in his
head whatever I'm feeling at the moment
I'm kind of honest 80s thing so like
when we do dishes or whatever I just be
you know the stranger things got me
stranger things seems long 80s playlist
oh yeah I don't play the full song I'm
like a DJ yeah I'll play like 30 seconds
and then the next song and then I get
bored of that when I play the next song
do you hear just like speaking English
is it more like more ambitious I like
Charlie Brown wah-wah wah-wah wah-wah
[Music]
you know the GPS when it's when it's
linked up to your car and the songs
going it's like that like hey make a
left here make a right at the next stop
that's what that's what happens guys
figured it out ya know she goes listen
to me cuz you don't know how to do it
and I'm like that's for I'm not gonna
fight you and I don't care like I don't
care if this is here or this is here it
doesn't matter to me because it's put
away but she has her specific way and
because she's logical it makes sense
like why you do it this way so then
since it makes sense I'm like okay like
I'm never gonna argue like no the spoons
should be over here like it's in a
drawer I don't care it's a way yeah yeah
it's like whatever you want sweetie like
that doing in cases like that too but
then now I feel like if you you know
we've been together for this long and
now that we're married maybe like it's
something else clicks in his head but
now I'm like extra annoying to him like
anything I do it's like all your nagging
and I'm like sorry abut I think I've
always been this big
yeah you've always been nagging yeah
always nagging around
hate nagging nagging is obnoxious to me
like I just there's a way to say things
and a way to do things you know didn't
mean nagging to me is if you're telling
me something that doesn't need to be
said or fixed it's the extra [ __ ] it's
extra so for example if I leave clothes
on the floor you could nag me about that
that's my bad you know I mean that's
cool that's a completely different story
but it's not [ __ ] like this it's like I
plug in the blow-dryer and I leave it
there because I'm gonna use it in about
five minutes
why are you doing that that's nagging
that's unnecessary cuz I'm use I
should've five minutes [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up I'll [ __ ] blow dry my head
when the [ __ ] I wanna blow dry my hair
you understand me your [ __ ] talk to me
like that [ __ ] that's what I think in
my head yeah that's Maggie yeah yeah
yeah that's not okay you know I'm saying
oh you do that I think all girls do it
though I just like to work around always
tell you to I'm like don't worry I have
a plan
Misha Blake why to roll down the windows
I'm like because I saw a cop three
blocks down in my windows are [ __ ]
tenant but for her it's just cold why'd
you leave all the windows down it's
because I have a plan I'm not trying to
get a [ __ ] ticket so I rolled the
windows down so four guys there's a plan
in the end they're mine why they're
doing something I'm not in this freezing
yeah yeah no but this I do for guys like
this there's a specific reason why we do
things but because no shalls' cat girls
can't read it
that's when girls have to say something
instead of just let it be no girls have
a reason why they say something or you
could X you could accent you roll down
the window oh you see that cop up there
three blocks down anybody oh okay saving
for a Casey and I right now we're in
that stage right now I'm just trying to
ask him find out why he did certain
things that way but then he immediately
already gets bothered by like even just
that so I'm like okay
weird problem now or a thing hmm cuz
then i follow point something out then
he'll be like oh you're nagging sin I'm
like I'm but I told you it might be it
might be too much like if it's done more
than once a week it might be too much
once a week I mean like if it's over
once a week then it becomes a lot at
this point let's say for the last
several years it's been every day
several times a day right then at that
point even if it's been once a week then
you're just like oh that's when people
are super sensitive because even if it's
only once a week it accumulated over the
fact that like now I'm just you could
hear it in my voice how annoyed I am so
- like there has to be a point to where
I think like in that type of
relationship where you know I think it's
normal but the same time it's like it if
you have to tell somebody
do one thing over and over that is a
problem because it should have been
fixed yeah cuz I can't deal with that
either so if I asked so if I asked like
for example there was one thing that
Mario's do that I didn't like when we
had conversations shouldn't do it
anymore
yeah one thing I don't have to do is
even if I'm joking I can't call it crazy
it takes work to break that habit I
think it's that it's a problem of habits
and living within because even as
roommates that [ __ ] we were roommates
cuz the other day - like I was joking
around as I act crazy when she goes what
did I say about that we're outside right
my bad so there has to be that
retraction though it can't be like did
you pick up because hey can you pick it
up and be all because it's still
technically his fault so if it was asked
and there was something agreed-upon you
say yeah we worked on other problems in
our relationship where you have gotten
better like that but now this is just
the new one normal stuff though we all
go through that it's always something
you're like cool we have a good month of
just awesomeness and then it's like that
girl wasn't [ __ ] up again for some
reason I feel like can is soul
home though that and I don't ever argue
about anything Dawson oh we won the
shower and I'm like oh sorry I forgot to
put the face wash back like in the
shower he's like oh it's okay I wasn't
gonna yell at you or anything I'm like
okay yeah I always am like oh I'm so
sorry and then he's like no don't trip
you know he's like you don't have to say
sorry or like I'm like messaging am I
facing I'm like sorry about this and
he's like don't be sorry I'm like the
[ __ ] you're like a rare breed dude [ __ ]
is with your apologetic understanding
that you tired of you every time I
apologize you tell me not to be sorry
can you stop being so [ __ ] perfect
and yeah that's that point where it's
like this could get boring cuz there's
nothing exciting happening no I'm not
fighting us relation no I've met people
like that I'm like so straight and I
like you like you know boring because
they don't fight I'm like that's awesome
we're talking about people are like oh
you need fights though it makes you
stronger it'll grow well you guys do
argue but you don't erupt like yeah yeah
I've seen your argument we lived with
each other but it's it doesn't get
anywhere like big yeah that's awesome
[Music]